I had alluded to a friend of ours
Lyle Asher who is a professor associate
professor full professor I remember
which of English at Lewis and Clark
College right here in Portland wrote an
article in 2018 I think it was for the
Chronicle of Higher Education which is
really the original and preeminent what
are you doing okay which is the original
and preeminent chronicle journal for
people in higher ed mostly for
administrators but many of us who have
been academics have been reading it and
he later because I was behind a paywall
did publish this in Aquila as well so
it's available without a paywall let me
just walk us through a little bit of
what his argument is and they were gonna
show a clip that was sent to us by
another friend of ours Mike Nina who was
doing extraordinary work in this regard
too so one of what his basic argument is
schools of higher education schools of
Education which our training have
historically trained teachers of k-12
students K through 12 students have no
history of excellence they have their
their famously not excellent ever every
moment that people have gone looking but
that more recently they have begun to
train not just teachers of children but
also administrators of colleges and
universities and not just administrators
of schools of Ed themselves but
administrators across the board so one
of the foundational papers in the
so-called scholarship in this realm that
has become really foundational for many
in schools of Education is on my core
microaggressions and in this paper is so
rife with sleight of hands sleight of
hand and so void of critical thinking
it's remarkable it was written by seven
academics at various schools of
Education or maybe it was all at one and
here's just a quote from this paper that
Asher takes two pieces they say again
this is the foundational is to sort of
the introduction of the concept of
microaggressions from if memory serves
maybe a 2014 paper micro aggressive acts
can usually be explained away by
seemingly non biased and valid reasons
for the recipient of a microaggression
however there is always the nagging
question of whether it really happened
it is difficult to identify a
microaggression especially when other
explanations seem plausible many people
of color describe a vague feeling that
they have been attacked and they have
been disrespected or that something is
not right
microaggressions operate to create
psychological dilemmas for both the
white perpetrator and the person of
color so Asher quotes this from this
paper and says why is everyone falling
for this kind of thinking which
explicitly pits villains against victims
it creates it creates exactly the
dynamic that is pretending to be
fighting against and he says why are
people not pushing back against this
garbage so just one quote here from him
he says because doing so yeah why not
why not tear apart
such clearly divisive pseudo scholars
scholarly thinking he says because doing
so would derail a deep nostalgia not of
course for the overt brutality and
dehumanization inflicted by Jim Crow and
the likes of Bull Connor but for the
moral certainty those evils which
respectively allow for in some respects
people of color may find an overt and
obvious racist act easier to handle the
essay that he's talking about obligingly
develops a crude alchemy for transmuting
the ambiguous into the obvious this
alchemy is little more than a way of
behaving that masquerades as a way of
knowing act as if ambiguities were
certainties and as a vague feelings for
reliable registers effect act in other
words as if complex interracial
encounters which have made of both
mistakes and misunderstandings are
conscious or unconscious acts of racism
exercised by a quote white perpetrator
that will indeed make things easier to
handle Asher
says one more from Asher but such ease
of handling is the product of
presumption and simplification it would
be as if a marriage counselor approached
every new couple have been decided in
advance that the complaints or
suspicions of the shorter partner or the
male partner or the
minority partner weren't necessarily
legitimate and the other spouses
objections prejudged as defensive were
evidence of guilt moreover because his
objections would in the author's pseudo
technical jargon invalidate the
experiential reality of the other
partner that is offer a different point
of view they would constitute yet
another offense would anyone expect
marital relations to improve under such
a counselor supervision would anyone
even hire such a counselor so you'd be
crazy to you'd be crazy to and this so
really I but cannot recommend this sa
highly enough it's it's so it's so good
and I don't know if we want to go right
into this little piece of video or you
want to say some things about what what
you just heard well I would agree with
you Lyle has been on this case for quite
some time and reading his work is very
sobering because he just cuts right to
the heart of it those quotes are
excellent and really point to it but
what I'm hoping people will do is they
will start to think about what the
architecture that is built up around
these claims becomes and what it looks
like going forward because of course the
thing that you've been saying for quite
some time is that as this moves into the
schools of IDI
it obviously moves into the children and
it moves into the children and therefore
cannot help but pervade society because
where do the children go absolutely
everywhere
[Music]